Donald's is going upscale for one night
and one night only and only by the way
in Japan on july 27th the chain will try
to boost its image there by ditching its
hallmark fast food menu and disposable
packaging meals will be served with
proper cutlery wine glasses as well and
diners will be treated to vichyssoise
mac fries can efface sighs more schools
of beef chicken and fish patties along
with variety of McDonald's dipping
sauces and wait wait oreo mcflurry
served with berries I should find the
vichyssoise is made from leeks onions
and potatoes so clueless okay the fries
are really good all right the thing is
not anyone can enjoy these meals you
actually have to get in line so to speak
it's open to just 10 groups of 20
lottery winning diners all of whom
already picked it this morning so we'll
have to wait to see them post their
pictures on Instagram on Twitter or
every 120 and ah but to broaden out I
mean this is what McDonald's is really
trying to do to boot customers back and
it's resorted to this I mean but that's
something right i mean we can both have
a lot of hype like we're talking about
it on TV that says like how they need to
position themselves in order to grow
their market share and they're kind of
tapped out yeah or maybe just come up
with better hamburgers Shh us what you
saw